like arguing and debating ending of
things for me it's however people are
using the word that's the meaning okay I
I concede that well we can get things
why I don't call myself an atheist it's
why you can look up the dictionary
definition of atheist and it kind of
applies to me but what is the definition
of atheist in practice it is what
leading atheists do and it's their
conduct and it's their behavior and it's
what they say and it's it's it's their
attitudes mm-hmm that is what an atheist
is today because they are the most
visible exemplars of that word and most
of their conduct I either don't agree
with or simply don't engage in what
don't you agree with I don't debate
religious people and tell them they're
idiots hmm I don't know it doesn't work
whether or not it works that's just not
it's not in me to do that I I don't
purge myself of words that have
religious foundations in them I once in
my facebook I had a friend going up in
orbit to repair the Hubble telescope one
of the astronauts and I said God speed
mm-hmm and then I gave the astronauts
name people wrote in in the thread said
I thought you were an atheist how can
you say Godspeed an atheist got angry
with me and I said okay first of all
this phrase is deeply historical in the
space program when John Glenn was
launched the headline was got speed John
Glenn mm every mission where we sent
human beings into space somewhere there
is that reference in the NASA fancy word
mean I'll tell you I'll tell you what it
means please do okay so oh by the way
I'll get to that in just one minute I'm
the atheist who are arguing that I was
using God's speed as a phrase they all
have used the phrase goodbye haven't
they see you later goodbye what does
that word come from it's from God be
with you it's a contraction of those
three words and why would you say this
you would say this to someone leaving
the city wall where it's dangerous okay
back when you had city-states you're
going to your god be with you to bring
protection
for you mm between one city on and
corrals look out for you so now what is
the source of danger if you're going to
space it's not alien space muggers it is
the fact that you have the space
Marauders it's the fact that you have
high speed and high speed is the source
of essentially any death of anything
that's in motion if you were part of
that disaster so god speed is like a
space equivalent to god be with you is
that really the origin well I'm just
saying
did they say that before there was space
travel did they say God speed I don't
know the actual origin of space travel
of the term I don't know how far back it
goes but I do know it became common
after John Glenn because they're not
gonna say it to Yuri Gagarin because
they were they're all a theists in in
the Soviet Union right but here in
America in America god speed John Glenn
and I respect that tradition and so I
said that and then they jumped so if a
theists are jumping on me for having
said that clearly I'm not an atheist and
asked me my favorite Broadway musical of
all time what's your favorite cheese's
Christ Superstar and I and I still use
BC and AD in my writings okay I still do
don't use BCE I don't use BCE hmm all
right well see even you cut cop in a
tube right there right yeah I saw your
face tell you why okay okay first of all
doesn't make any sense VCE is not the
current era 2,000 years ago I'm gonna
tell you so BCE as you know stands for
before Common Era right and c e stands
for Common Era so this is d religious of
fiying ad and BC NB C right okay yet of
course they reference the same calendar
right okay well who invented the
calendar we all currently use in modern
society it's called the Gregorian
calendar it was invented by the Catholic
Church by Jesuit priests in the 1580s
assigned by Pope Gregory to fix the
problems in the calendar because I'm
sorry screaming at you here you
started screen get crazy I gotta calm
down I'll bring in coffee the Julian
calendar put forth in ancient Rome had
one modification to previous calendars
it had a leap day okay
it had a leap day and okay
leap day is how often every four years
this was good because what are we trying
to track we try to earth goes around the
Sun and so we say alright how long does
that take well it takes a year but it
turns out we're not actually tracking
how long it takes earth to go around the
Sun without tracking how long it takes
earth to repeat its seasons and the
repeat the year that corresponds to our
seasons is slightly different from the
year that corresponds to how long it
takes to go around the Sun slightly
different and that difference was not
recognized in the early calendars and
that difference accumulated so that by
the year fifteen eighty four the vernal
equinox the first day of spring did not
occur on March 21st it occurred on March
10th it shifted from the calendar date
that's what happens if you don't match
the cycles of things and the Pope said
we're not having any of this
especially since Easter might land on
Passover and we try to distinguish
ourselves mightily from the Jews so
let's fix this the Jesuit priest got to
study this they looked at the cycles of
the heavens the Sun the Moon the Stars
and they came up with a new calendar the
Gregorian calendar a modification to the
Julian calendar you know what they have
to do to invoke it that to take ten days
out of the calendar to jumpstart to put
the first day of spring back on March
21st then this happened in October 15 84
why is there been 10 days out of the
calendar so now how much rent do you pay
they have to like invent amortized rent
yeah cuz you're gonna pay for three
weeks instead you know twenty days
instead of 30 did they have to figure
that out okay point is this was
hard-earned and the whole world uses
this calendar it is the most accurate
calendar ever devised in it yes I'll
tell you what okay you asked
so watch what happens the leap day
overcorrected the calendar get
overcorrected over correct yes yes so
you need a leap year so no so the leap
day is every four years that one day
every four years was slowly putting too
many days into the moments into the year
okay the Gregorian calendar figured this
out and it had put ten extra days since
the Julian calendar to the Gregorian
calendar ten extra days first jump start
get rid of the ten days now everything's
lined up again okay now how do you
prevent this from happening again
because it over corrects how long do you
have to wait to remove a leap day that
you would otherwise put in okay okay
that's every hundred years
oh so every hundred years that would be
a leap day you remove the leap day now
turns out that under corrects it by an
even smaller amount okay so how long do
you have to wait before you have to put
a leap day back in every 400 years Oh
God
so the year 2000 was a century year
which normally would not have a leap day
except it's a century year evenly
divisible by 400 so they put the leap
day back in and everybody on February
almost everybody everybody except the
astronomers on February 29th in the year
2000 set it's just a leap year because
it's divisible by 4 no it is a rarely
Pierre it is a century year divisible by
400 that corrects it back and so now you
have a stable calendar for tens of
thousands of years I got to give props
to the Jesuit priest I'm not gonna say
no I'm taking the Christianity out of
this reference because they figured out
the calendar that we all use and it's a
[ __ ] awesome count sorry to drop an
f-bomb so I'm not just because some
atheists are telling me that rid God out
of everything in the universe that I'm
not I'm not doing that I'm going to say
they came up with this calendar
the reasons were because they didn't
want to confuse it with Passover the
motivation is whatever it is but the
sciences is good and so there it is